q
sept mois choqué la prise
tellement d'endroits ça fait quoi de
naviguer en solitaire ce qu'on ressent
est incroyable
j'irai nulle part sans toi
faut qu'on s'inquiète
blois damrémont vient de passer en
catégorie 5 je t'aime on tient pas dans
la cabine
[Musique]
au mondial à vous
pourquoi tahiti qu'est ce qui t'amène si
je veux vivre une grande aventure
wow c'est qu'ils se méfient
l oreille
l'aco
ça fait quoi naviguer en solitaire
d'abord du manque de sommeil telles mal
de mer et au bout de quelques jours
arrivent les hallucinations
alors pourquoi tu le fais parce que ce
composant est incroyable ya que toi
face à l'horizon infini
cette dirait dans des lieux azaña
jusqu'en californie
tu en penses quoi elle naviguait sur
6500 km c'est de la folie j'irai nulle
force s'il te plaît viens avec moi
voyage en amoureux
[Musique]
l'ouragan des mots évoluent de façon
inattendue
il vient de passer en catégorie 5 vaut
mieux qu'on vérifie que tout est arrivé
donc on s'inquiète
brisard
ouais ça va aller je vais m'occuper de
toi mais à des milliers de kilomètres de
la terre
pouvoir est rien ça donne une zone de
recherche de 4000 kilomètres carrés
d'eau dans l'océan
kapan al khatib
chez les côtes cassées et les chambres
ici
un poids mort
on peut peut-être essayer hawaï c'est
comme viser une cible mouvante à 3000 km
si tu loupes hawaï
si je loupe hawaï en aimant jeu
v on peut tout faire si on veut vraiment
[Musique]
j'ai parcouru la moitié de la terre pour
te trouver
réponse